[Music]
what happens when you cross your
favorite Disney characters put the
characters from Game of Thrones
we won't ruin the surprise but you
better believe it's way cooler than you
could ever imagine so if you've ever
wondered what character Elsa would be in
Game of Thrones make sure to stick
around until the end of the video don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
more stories like this and give this
video a big thumbs up now join us as we
take a look at ten Disney characters
reimagined in Game of Thrones
Mulan everyone knows that Milan is one
of the toughest Disney Princesses around
and if anyone needs proof of her courage
they need not look any further than the
film Mulan in this classic Disney movie
from 1998 Milan proves her grit over and
over again in fact she's so fierce and
passionate that she actually dressed up
as a male soldier named King just to
take her father's place in the Imperial
Army luckily for her Milan is not alone
in her grand adventure she's joined by
the second coolest character in the film
her little dragon friend Moo shoo boo
shoe is really very funny almost as
funny as the famous comedian Jerry
Seinfeld this pair takes their mission
very seriously and worked tirelessly to
integrate themselves into the Imperial
Army while Mulan skills are initially
very weak she quickly learns to become
an extremely effective soldier and gains
the respect of her peers even when her
true identity is revealed and she's
discharged from the army
Milan continues to fight for what she
thinks is right in the end she ends up
saving the day and is highly rewarded
for her service a lady this tough
deserves to be matched with a truly
intense game of Thrones character the
artist that made this photo picked the
right lady when she reimagined Mulan as
Arya Stark Arya is fiercely independent
just like Mulan and we think the two are
match made in heaven
that like many Disney movies The Beauty
and the Beast is actually based on an
old fairy tale this story is especially
old though and has actually been around
since 1740 you know the story must be
pretty amazing when it's withstood the
test of time at the heart of this tragic
love story is one of our favorite Disney
Princesses Belle her beauty is only
passed by her incredible intellect and
courage in the face of adversity you
have to be pretty tough to see the
beauty in someone as daunting as the
Beast
and that's exactly what Belle does as
she learns to love a creature that is
trapped in his own nightmare despite her
beauty and intelligence this young lady
is actually treated as an outcast by the
other residents of her town in the face
of this Belle becomes an extremely tough
and resilient character that should
inspire anyone watching the film as this
heroic princess longs for a world
outside of her simple small town we
watch as she risks her life and fights
to save her father a beacon of true
altruism this is one special lady when
sorting through the world of Game of
Thrones the artists of this amazing
picture chose the perfect match for
Belle in Margaery Tyrell just like the
princess Marjorie is stuck in
unfortunate circumstances as she's
married to the horrible King Joffrey but
in the face of unfortunate situations
you can count on these two ladies to
show unbelievable faith and courage
Rapunzel
if you haven't seen the Disney movie
Tangled then you would probably be
pretty surprised to see Rapunzel with
short hip hair and you'd be right to get
caught off guard
since this classic princess has been
associated with her long flowing blonde
hair for over 200 years did you know
that the character of Rapunzel actually
originally came from an old German fairy
tale that's right this classic fairy
tale was first assembled by the Brothers
Grimm in their book children and
household tales
published way back in 1812 pretty old
don't you think since its first
publication the story of Rapunzel has
remained a favorite for people of all
ages it was so popular in fact that
Disney decided to give the princess her
very own movie in 2010 in this modern
adaptation Disney made the bold choice
to have Rapunzel lose her signature hair
must have been pretty shocking to
longtime fans less shocking was their
decision to have this blonde beauty
voiced by the famous singer Mandy Moore
we can't think of a better match but
when it comes to Game of Thrones one
artist has a pretty strange match for
the short-haired Rapunzel that's right
check out our fair lady reimagined as
one of the most wicked women in the Game
of Thrones series Cersei Lannister how
could a princess so sweet play a queen
so evil upon closer inspection it seems
that there might even be a hint of
confusion and Rapunzel's eyes to Merida
how special is Princess Merida from
Disney's major motion picture brave well
let us count the ways first off this red
haired lady was actually Pixar's first
leading lady it's about time Pixar
seriously Merida was also the 11th
princess in Disneyland up and he think
that's pretty cool not only that but
this feisty lady was also the first
Scottish princess in the entire Disney
Princess franchise you go girl
throughout the movie brave Merida proves
for bravery time and time again at the
same time the little wild princess has a
disdain for authority that kicks her
into a little bit of trouble in fact
when her mother Queen Elinor tells me
that she needs to get married the young
lady runs off and starts scheming on
ways to defy the Queen the distraught
young girl explains the whole marriage
situation to an old witch who then casts
a terrible spell on one of the most
delicious-looking pieces of gift we've
ever seen this piece of cake turns Queen
Elinor into a terrifying beast America
spends the rest of the film trying to
undo the awful mistake she's made she
eventually succeeds of course not bad
for a sixteen-year-old if you ask us
given how wild and independent this
young princesses it only makes sense
that her Game of Thrones character would
be your grass one of the fiercest Wyland
in the whole entire series the artist
did such an incredible job creating the
image that it's easy to imagine seeing
Merida with Jon Snow defeating the wall
by Sun grandmother [ __ ]
one of the most memorable characters in
the entire Mulan film has to be
grandmother fought grandma's wisdom can
be read in her soft smile and deep
wrinkles in her face she's got all the
best qualities of grandmother she's
sassy and spunky and she's never afraid
to speak her mind do you have a
grandmother like that you know the one
who always asked about your latest crush
gives you a wink and slips a tooth
breaking caramel into your pocket
well that's grandma saw all right beyond
her attitude thaw is steeped in age-old
Chinese tradition and she has a focal
point for guidance throughout the film
with such a sweet caring lady one has to
wonder who his grandmother Fabi and Game
of Thrones well the artist Gregory
Munsters actually made an interesting
choice to reimagine fought at the
indomitable Elana Terra ulema is the
elderly matriarch of the Tyrell family
and she's one tough cookie in fact
throughout the Seven Kingdoms she is
often referred to as queen of thorns
that is definitely not a nickname we'd
want to have but Elena's anger and wrath
are certainly understandable given that
she's lost nearly her entire family at
the hand of Cersei Lannister
it is this tragedy that provokes the
eldest Tyrell to pledged her allegiance
to the dragon queen Wow grandma bought
an Elena may be quite different in their
approach this picture blends them
together with impressive fluidity Ariel
when you think of Disney one of the
first movies that comes to mind is
probably the Little Mermaid indeed
anyone who's ever seen this flick has
probably had the song under the sea
stuck in their head at one point do you
know that this classic film was actually
based on a Danish fairy tale of the same
name well the Disney film debuted in
1989 the original fairy tales dates back
as far as 1837 if it's been around that
long you know it must be good the story
would be nothing without its main
character the sweet and highly
compelling area having spent her entire
life
under the sea Ariel develops a keen
desire to experience life on the shore
when she makes her first trip outside of
the seat young mermaid meets and rescues
a young prince Erik Ariel then returns
to the ocean but her love for Erik
remains
desperate to reconnect with him Ariel
visits Ursula a maniac
Jewish who Tom early turns Ariel into a
human in exchange for her voice after
many trials and tribulations the young
lady proves her love for Eric and has
permanently transformed into a human
from then on the two live happily ever
after with Ariel's intense passion it
only makes sense that her Game of
Thrones character would be Yara Greyjoy
Yara is one of the most intense
characters from the Greyjoy family and
her familiarity with the seat makes the
comparison all the more appropriate with
all that in mind we think this artist
really nailed it jasmine the story of
Aladdin is one of the most beloved his
knee tails of all time and the film
would be nothing without its Princess
Jasmine wig Aladdin premiered in 1992
Jasmine became an instant favorite among
kids and adults of all ages and she
remains one of the most inspiring Disney
Princesses of all time this young lady
was born into a society where she was
treated as an object rather than a
person and it's this strong oppression
that leads her to become a strong
individual although the film is based in
Jasmine's tragic upbringing
Aladdin introduces so many memorable
characters it's hard to keep track first
on the list has to be the princess's
love interest Aladdin and his radical
monkey sidekick and we can't forget one
of the most classic characters of all
time the genie inside the magic lamp did
you know that the character of genie was
actually voiced by Robin Williams of the
critically acclaimed film flubber pretty
cool right all four of these characters
unite throughout the film to battle
against the evil Jafar through the power
of love and some True Grit
they are able to stop Jafar from
attained power so badly desires with the
princess as toughest Jasmine her Game of
Thrones doppelganger needs to be
somebody pretty fierce the artist
Gregory monsura certainly didn't
disappoint since there are not many
ladies tougher than el arias and we
certainly wouldn't want to get on this
lady's bad side Queen Eleanor there may
be no Queen more heroic than Queen
Eleanor from the Disney movie brave
she's got to be pretty cool since this
is the mother of the film's main
character Merida compared to her more
short-sighted husband King Fergus
Eleanor is much more deliberate and she
carries the responsibility of the entire
Kingdom on her shoulders due to this
enormous responsibility Queen Eleanor is
often seen as a very strict and
by-the-book ruler this attitude also
translates into her parenting style and
you better believe this royal lady
expects Merida to follow in her
footsteps although she sometimes rules
with a hard fist Eleanor is extremely
intelligent ladylike and admirable even
in the face of adversity and struggle
she always keeps calm in fact when
Merida turns her into a bear Eleanor has
enough self-awareness to treat the whole
mishap has a powerful learning
experience where some people might be
steeped in anger at being turned into a
bear eleanor learns to appreciate the
skills that Merida has that she herself
does not now that's true parenting when
considering who Queen Eleanor may be
inside the world of Game of Thrones this
artist must have been racking his brain
to think of someone that embodies the
same kind of dignity let's just say he
hit the nail on the head by choosing
Catelyn Stark to blend with the Queen
Eleanor both ladies are extremely
dignified and no surprise here
they're both mothers Pocahontas the
story of Pocahontas is an attempt to
explore the relationship between Native
Americans and settlers in early America
while the movie has been criticized for
its historical inaccuracies it's still a
captivating tale of a forbidden love set
in the early 1600s the beginning of
Disney's Pocahontas finds the titular
princess and the rest the Powhatan tribe
hanging out in Virginia Pocahontas the
daughter of the chief Powhatan has an
awesome necklace she got from her mother
and spent her time talking shop with a
raccoon and a hummingbird everything is
going pretty well until the settlers
show up in a big ship hungry for gold
the expedition is led by none other than
Captain John Smith and governor
Ratcliffe when they land Ratcliffe has
the crew begin digging for gold
while Smith's us often explore the new
land it is during this adventure that
Captain John Smith first encounters a
lovely Pocahontas the two have an
unexpected connection and throughout the
film they nurture a budding romance even
though it was widely seen as taboo to do
so when the rest of the settlers and the
Powhatan tribe find out about this
forbidden love they all tried their best
to separate the couple
in the end though love prevails and both
sides are able to accept the
relationship with such a calm and
peaceful princess like Pocahontas it
only seems right that this artist chose
to liken her to Game of Thrones
character miss Andy both of these women
enjoy a sense of calm trust and we think
they definitely belong together
Elsa princess Elsa from the Disney movie
frozen has a pretty incredible magical
power yes this chilly princess was
actually born with the incredible
ability to control ice and snow we wish
someone would tell her to make it stop
snowing so much in the winter time
unfortunately Elsa is not initially able
to control her powers and it gets her
into some big trouble
on the night that Elsa is able to become
monarch of ardent Oh she accidentally
unleashes an eternal winter on her new
kingdom oops
while this mistake initially causes Elsa
and the town some major trouble it also
leads her on a journey that will change
her life forever
by the end of the film the young
princess has learned to control her
powers and return to arendelle back to
its normal climate when considering who
Elsa might be in the series Game of
Thrones Daenerys Targaryen is the
obvious choice much like the frozen
princess Daenerys has the ability to
control forces much greater than her own
but rather than controlling ice and snow
this powerful blonde woman controls some
incredibly fierce fire-breathing dragons
Daenerys actually raises these little
flying creatures from the time that they
are just little babies as the Dragons
grow to their full size they become some
of the most feared creatures in all of
the Seven Kingdoms
while Elsa and Daenerys certainly use
their powers in different ways the
resemblance is absolutely undeniable is
there a Disney character that you'd like
to see reimagined in Game of Thrones let
us know in the comments thanks for
watching
[Music]